l'endroit fait penser à une salle de
jeux mais il s'agit en réalité d'une
salle de cours les élèves en formation
appartiennent aux Forces Spéciales
ukrainiennes deux semaines
d'entraînement pour apprendre à opérer
des drones avec vue immersive
une munition sera ensuite attachée à
l'appareil
vous pouvez économiser un missile
antichard Javelin parce que le drone
peut aller aussi loin que le Javelin le
drone coûte environ 600 dollars un
missile Javelin coûte environ 80 à 120
000 dollars
c'est moi qui ai voulu venir ici la
technologie avance on doit avancer avec
les drones sont assemblés ici en Ukraine
leur fabrication fait l'objet d'une
course de vitesse avec la Russie qui a
rattrapé son retard d'après le
responsable du programme
ils essayent de copier ce qu'on fait
d'abord c'était avec les drones
commerciaux et maintenant avec les
drones immersif kamikaze ça va empirer
si quelqu'un dans leur gouvernement
réalise que cette technologie doit être
utilisée ils vont dépenser beaucoup
d'argent peut-être pas de manière
efficace mais ils vont produire une
grande quantité de jouets nous on a des
difficultés à obtenir les pièces
détachées l'Ukraine aspire tout ce
qu'elle peut dans les pays voisins
toutes les pièces et tout ce qui est
produit en Chine et commander soit par
nous soit par les Russes
au Lexis occupe de la fabrication de ces
drones kamikazes il lui faut une heure
pour construire un appareil il voudrait
désormais trouver une solution pour
contourner les contre-mesures des forces
russes
ils utilisent des stations très
puissantes sur le terrain pour brouiller
nos drones donc tout ce qu'on peut faire
pour l'instant c'est que les gars
reçoivent la confirmation qu'à tel
endroit il n'y a pas de contre-mesure et
ensuite seulement il vole
une fois assemblée les drones sont
livrés aux unités un capitaine des
forces spéciales les reçoit aujourd'hui
il dit avoir besoin de syndrome kamikaze
par semaine sur sa position